Speaker 1: We're continuing our interviews
with all sorts of different 2022 candidates.
And today I'm going to be speaking with Adam
Stein, who's a self-described America first
candidate, endorsed by the former president,
Donald Trump, currently running a write in
campaign in the 63rd District for the Wisconsin
State Assembly.
Adam, I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 3: Thanks for having me, David.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So indulge me.
I know this.
We may get through this first question in
one word and then we can move on.
But it's just a good gut check.
Who is the current president of the United
States?
Speaker 3: Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Oh, the current president is Trump.
Speaker 3: No.
Right.
Right now it's Joe Biden, sir.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Did he legitimately when do you think does
his presidency reflect the will of the voters?
Speaker 3: I believe, especially here in the
state of Wisconsin, we have some major questions
that we'd like to ask, and we have not been
able to bring those before a judge here in
the state of Wisconsin.
Speaker 1: Who is preventing you from doing
that?
Speaker 3: Right now, the only person that
we can find is my opponent, Robin Barnes.
He has said multiple times that he is going
to do a full forensic cyber audit when he
got off the plane with the president back
August of last year.
And he has done absolutely nothing of the
sort in order to find out really what people
want to know, David.
They want to know that their ballot counts,
their vote is actually counted.
That's all they want to know.
Speaker 1: And what reason do we have right
now to question the results in which Joe Biden
won that state by 20,000 votes?
What specifically do we have?
Speaker 3: In Wisconsin.
Yes.
Let's go.
JOHNSON So we have the Supreme Court announcing
their ruling back about a month and a half
ago that the ballot drop boxes are and were
illegal.
There's two methods of delivering your ballot
in the state of Wisconsin Constitution.
By statute, you can deliver it in the mail
or you can deliver it in person to the clerk.
The Wisconsin Election Commission decided
to add a third option, which is a ballot drop
box, which is not clearly defined in the statute.
So when the Supreme Court ruled, they said
those drop boxes are and were illegal.
So there were about 250,000 votes cast.
Speaker 1: But Adam, hold on a second.
Hold on.
I know.
You're two too good to do this to us.
You know that if you read that decision, what
they found was that there were some locations
that were not accessible to individuals with
mobility issues.
And they did they said nothing substantive
about fraud related to the final count or
anything of the sort.
Speaker 3: No, no, no, no.
I was simply giving you the reasoning.
You're exactly right.
I would not mean to admit that.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Fair.
Speaker 3: Very correct, David.
Very, very correct.
The amount of ballots that were cast by that
method, in lieu of the fact that it doesn't
follow the method to deliver the ballot by
the Constitution.
Yeah.
Would in my case bring to question the fact
that those ballots, whether legal or not,
were cast in an unlawful manner.
You're exactly right.
Okay.
Speaker 1: And do you also admit that while
it is totally within your right to extrapolate
whatever you want based on that decision,
the justices who who wrote the dissenting
opinion say when people say the types of things
you're saying, you're fanning political flames
in a way that is not good.
You're making people think you're talking
about fraudulent results.
When all they said was some of these weren't
accessible to people with disabilities, that's
all they said.
Speaker 3: So what what they said, if you
read the final decision.
Yes.
That the method of delivery is to observe.
Right.
So there's two methods of delivery in the
statute.
Yes.
Wisconsin Election Commission introduced a
third without going through this, the legislature.
So that to me is an extremely scary position
to be in.
The Supreme Court said that those those boxes
that were used were not under the method of
which deliberation was described in the Constitution.
So you are correct.
I'm not trying to say that the Supreme Court
said the elections of ballot, none of that
good.
Speaker 1: They just said they should have
all been accessible to individuals with disabilities.
Yep.
So.
Okay.
Speaker 3: The next thing that I'd like to
point out is we had Justice Gable on 139 page
report.
And I would really like for that report to
be put before a judge.
And I would like the judicial system to actually
make a ruling on the findings of that report.
Okay.
So the Wisconsin Election Commission decided
to remove special voting deputies, right?
They said they were not necessary in 2020.
And I believe from my bottom of my heart,
my great grandmother died at 102 at our house
that they were.
That they were removed.
And we had people that were executing the
elections and collecting ballots that were
not under the constitution.
They were not followed.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So you've you've raised a couple of concerns
that that's fair.
And but you're also conceding that on that
first one, it's really about disability rights.
Let me ask you this.
What is a forensic election audit?
Because and the reason I ask is everybody
I ask has a different explanation.
And when I point to audits that have that
have been done, folks will invariably say
that's not really the type of audit I'm talking
about.
Speaker 3: Hmm.
Got it.
That's a very fair question, because you're
exactly right, David.
Let's go across the country.
Right.
You look at Arizona.
Yeah.
And look at Georgia.
Even here in Wisconsin.
The the audit that that we'd like to find
out is what happens to your ballot when it
goes through the machine.
I'm not telling you the machines are fraudulent.
I can't tell you that, David.
You can't tell me that.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I certainly can't tell you the machines are
fraudulent because I have no reason to believe
that.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: And.
And I can't either.
Right.
So good.
Can I. Can I maybe reframe this discussion
a little bit so.
Speaker 1: You can reframe it?
But I would love an answer to what you mean
by a forensic election.
All right.
Speaker 3: I apologize.
So a forensic audit is when when your ballot
is cast, right?
Yes.
The process by which your ballot is cast.
Once that ballot goes into whether it's scanned
or a machine goes into a box in a county,
courthouse gets counted.
Yes.
And the total results are finished.
I believe that process should be clear to
the public.
So a forensic audit to me is understanding
every step of that process without equivocation.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Now, let me see if I understand
it.
And you tell me the elements that are missing.
Right.
Because I've voted with these types of machines
before.
I have a ballot.
I take my felt sharpie and I sort of like
connect to little black things and make it
a fixed line.
I feed it in through a machine.
Presumably the machine identifies which line
I drew and credits that candidate with a vote.
And then my ballot goes into a pile, and then
later you could go back in and count up the
pieces of paper with the lines and compare
it to the results from the machine.
Is that a fair process?
Speaker 3: That that process.
Yeah.
Is that part of the audit?
Okay.
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Speaker 1: And what else is there?
Speaker 3: Well, for me in Wisconsin, we have
a process called early absentee voting, and
that's 47 days that starts September 22nd
for the general election, in my opinion.
Based on the I'd say the evidence, if you
will, that has never been presented before
a court that we have men and women here in
Wisconsin.
There's a there was a case yesterday that
they heard the DOJ brought against a man by
the name of Harry Wade.
Harry Waite requested a ballot, an absentee
ballot for five people with their birth date
in their first and last name.
That's the only thing you need to request
their ballot if they voted absentee in the
past.
There's no I.D.
required.
Because they've already submitted a request
for an absentee ballot.
The problem that I have is, let's say that
what you and I just described as perfectly
flawless.
Right.
I'll concede that.
Let's say it's perfectly flawless.
If you and I would like to request ballots
from an individual who has voted one out of
the last 15 election cycles, and we submit
it by an absentee ballot in a mailbox or drop.
There is no way for you and I. Based on the
process you just defined.
To confirm or deny whether or not that ballot
was cast by that individual.
Speaker 1: So a few things on that because
I've heard and read about this many, many
times before.
There's a few different things.
Number one is, even if what you're saying
is true in theory, someone could do that.
I could find someone who hasn't voted in a
really long time.
I'm admitting you're right.
I could I could try to figure out who hasn't
voted in a really long time, request the ballot
in their name, and then fill it out and send
it in.
Fine.
In order for us to be able to say it's worth.
X, Y or Z.
Audit, investigation, whatever.
I would want to, number one, have evidence
that that happened in numbers that could have
swayed the results.
And in order to believe that, I would have
to have reason to think that one side rather
than the other was disproportionately doing
it.
Because even if I grant that what you're saying
could be done and was done, if it was done
equally by Republicans and Democrats, it doesn't
actually change the outcome, does it?
Does my math check out at least Adam.
In other words, if 10,000 Republicans do that
and 10,000 Democrats do that with these people
who haven't voted in a while, Biden still
wins by 20,000 votes.
Right?
The math checks out at least.
Oh.
And is he was that question too tough?
I can't believe that was why he left.
Adam, where are you?
Oh, my.
I think he bailed because of that question.
What on earth?
Adam.
Don't tell me that question was too difficult.
Adam, you're back.
Speaker 3: We were on hold.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you put.
I thought you bailed because that you didn't
like the question.
Speaker 3: No, sir.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So my question was, I'm glad you're back.
My question was, if 10,000 Democrats and 10,000
Republicans do the thing you described, it
doesn't change the margin of victory.
So the question I have is, what evidence do
we have that what you just described as possible
was not only done, but was done by so many
more Democrats than Republicans that it would
change the outcome in Wisconsin.
Speaker 3: I would like to contend that your
premise of your question is wrong.
Okay.
Well, I agree with your question.
Speaker 1: Tell me how it's wrong.
Speaker 3: Well, so my grandfather was in
the 82nd Airborne Division.
We have men and women who have died for this
country so that we can have the right to vote
yes.
I personally believe that if you use the line
of questioning that you've so chosen that
if both sides do it, it's okay.
Speaker 1: That's not the that's not what
I said, though.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1: So it's a two part question.
First, go ahead.
What evidence do we have that this was done
in large numbers at all?
Because that's been investigated in Wisconsin.
And part two is, if it was done in large numbers,
was it done disproportionately by one side?
Speaker 3: So I would love absolutely love
to hear, first of all, the premise of the
investigation that happened, because this
is the perfect crime, David, for you to say
that someone voted absentee and their ballot
was determined that they actually did vote
absentee and it was found that they really
didn't vote because that would take a canvass.
When I say a full forensic audit that would
take a canvass of the people that actually
were elected or voted in this election.
Speaker 1: So you're saying go door knocking
all the people who supposedly voted and say,
did you really vote?
Speaker 3: Well, no, no, no.
I'm asking your question.
You said that that was investigative police.
Tell me, how was that investigated?
Because that's the only method I know to verify
what you just said.
Speaker 1: Well, you do it with a sample.
It was, in fact, you.
I mean, so again, if the standard is you want
to look up every absentee vote and then go
and check with the person, did you vote?
It could be done.
It would require an insane amount of resources
in.
When we when we talk about science, when we
talk about mathematical significance, you
can take a sample of those and investigate
them.
And when we do that, when we take a representative
sample, we find a combination of things.
You know, usually a few people who were alive
when they sent in their absentee ballot and
died by Election Day, they didn't do anything
wrong that sometimes people die.
You find examples of like junior, senior confusion
where, yes, a junior voted as their dead father,
but the dead father didn't vote.
So it doesn't it's still just one vote.
It was just counted for the right.
You get to this point where there's really
nothing there when you test a representative
sample.
So again, for me to say let's check everyone,
I would want to have a sample that raises
concerns and that that hasn't happened when
it's been looked at in Wisconsin.
Wisconsin.
Speaker 3: So so just to be clear, but I did
not know.
And you're telling me that we did actually
sample a county because we did canvasing here
in Wisconsin in Racine County.
Yeah.
We found 400 people voting from a single family
household.
Okay.
In the 2020 election.
So if if you have different evidence, let's
talk about that.
But right now, I would love love to do some
digging, but I'm not going to sit and argue.
Fair.
Speaker 1: Fair.
Okay.
I think I've raised enough questions for you
to understand the origins of my skepticism.
And you've pointed out what you ask.
So I think we can we can move on.
But you have questions that you don't feel
have been answered.
Speaker 3: Just just one more thing, sir.
Seriously, with with regards to our election,
that to me the issue is really can be solved
in eight words.
It's simple.
I would like our election process to be done
in-person on paper and count one day.
Speaker 1: And that would apply to Donald
Trump as well.
Right, because he voted earlier, months, early
by mail.
He wouldn't be able to do that.
Speaker 3: Every person except the military
and our elderly that are able to get out and
vote, because to me, the men and women of
this country that have given their lives so
that you and I can have the freedom to even
have this conversation.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: Vote, they died and gave their
lives so that we could take the responsibility
that we have to make sure we go vote.
In my election process right?
In just my little district.
Yep.
Less than 10% voted in the primary.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's depressing.
And that's common and sadly, low voter engagement.
I want more voter engagement.
Speaker 3: It is.
But.
But I guess to me, the solution is I would
like transparency a lot of the questions that
you and I are discussing.
Our system has been set up so that you and
I can't come to a conclusion.
We can't come to a realistic idea that we
know that our vote was counted and cast.
Clearly, no one was.
Speaker 1: Adam.
Listen, I got it.
I want to get some.
Some other topics.
One of the things I found super interesting
was at one point you wrote you would outlaw
contraceptives if you were given that opportunity.
Do I have that right?
And why would you do that?
Speaker 3: Well, conveniently enough, you
don't have it correct.
Okay.
That was The New York Post, I believe it was.
Was that were the.
Yes.
Speaker 1: I don't have the source in front
of me.
I read a bunch of stuff before I interview
you.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: I did not write that.
They asked me what I believed personally.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: And I said very clearly that I
do believe that life begins at conception.
Your body is your choice, and you make a decision
before conception happens.
Okay.
You and I are adults.
We know how children are come to this world.
And if you make a choice, there's a consequence
for that choice.
I personally believe that stopping the natural
progression of life, which you again made
a decision in order to engage in sexual activity
as a person, as an individual, that is something
that I believe is wrong to stop life as a
as a representative.
I'm not going to put the lid back on Pandora's
box.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So you wouldn't move to ban contraception,
but you're against it.
You in other words, you believe even a condom
is stopping the process of life.
Speaker 3: Personally.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm talking about you personally.
I know.
It's just you personally.
Speaker 3: Well, there's a difference between
policy and personal.
Yeah, so.
So personally, yes.
I believe that you are actually just making
a decision to engage in an activity and you
want to remove the consequence.
Speaker 1: And this applies not just to oral
contraceptives and plan B, but you're saying
even a condom is interfering with is it is
it God's will that you fight?
Is it religiously based or where are you coming
up with this?
Speaker 3: No, I'm saying you're trying to
remove the consequence of your decision.
You want to enjoy an activity that you have
a physical pleasure.
Yeah.
And you think removing the consequence that
is, wouldn't.
Speaker 1: That apply also to, for example,
wearing a seatbelt in a car where the natural
consequence of driving fast might be that
you get hurt in an accident and the seatbelt
is artificially keeping you safe?
I mean, it's sort of a weird argument, isn't
it?
Speaker 3: It's a weird argument.
Safe, safe safety and saving a life versus
ending a life to me is an interesting.
Speaker 1: But you consider wearing a condom
to be ending a life.
Speaker 3: Well, you're preventing a life,
correct?
So maybe it's deferring a consequence.
That's what I'm saying.
Speaker 1: Wow.
That's interesting.
I've never I've honestly I've heard right
wingers say insurance assurance shouldn't
cover some of these things, but I've never
heard anyone say that condoms are just straight
up wrong.
That's.
So you're saying that view.
It's not based on your religious beliefs.
Speaker 3: No.
I believe that like they.
Think about life.
If life doesn't begin at conception.
If you don't defend life at all stages, whether
it be war, end at what level?
What party?
At what point does life have value?
Well.
Speaker 1: If you're using a condom, there's
been no conception.
Right.
You're going even earlier.
Speaker 3: You say what happens at the end
of life, sir, if you're telling me that we'd
like to have no consequences for any decision
that you make, that's why you're telling me
that we would like to have plan B?
Well, I decided to have sex, right?
That's.
That's all.
That's all conception happens.
I would like to defer that consequence.
I'm not going to say that government is going
to legislate morality.
No.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 3: That as a legislator.
Speaker 1: Wow.
That this is mind blowing.
Adam, I've never heard this from anyone.
I mean, you may be in some way the most socially
conservative person.
No condoms and.
And you.
So how old were you when you came to this
view, this anti condom view?
Speaker 3: When you say empty column again,
it makes it kind of sound funny.
Speaker 1: Well, it is very funny, I think.
I mean, it's very you're saying we have to
defend all life and like, are you is masturbation
wrong?
And I ask that.
Speaker 3: Is masturbation.
Speaker 1: Wrong?
Right.
Because then you're talking about millions
of potential lives that are.
No, never going to get a chance.
Speaker 3: But as as an individual.
Speaker 1: Yeah, all as an individual.
Speaker 3: What I have been taught and I have
come to the conclusion in my life, you know,
that I believe that you are enjoying an activity,
that there's nothing wrong with it.
But at the end of the day, you are actually,
like you said, you are snuffing out life.
But I have.
Speaker 1: Now.
Speaker 3: Probation is is illegal, sir.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Adam, we are treading incredible new ground
here.
I have to say.
This is this is going to be I can't think
of a more interesting note on which we would
end than that.
But this is really giving me a lot of a lot
to think about, I think, for lack of a better
term.
The election is in November.
Adam Stein is running to represent District
63 in the Wisconsin State Assembly.
He has been endorsed by Donald Trump.
We don't know whether Donald Trump is on the
same page on some of the condom stuff.
I think it would be interesting to to talk
to him about that.
But Adam, I appreciate so much for your time
today and you laying out some of your views.
Speaker 3: Thanks, David.
I appreciate.